well today's Bloomberg big number is  40,000 pounds that is how much marijuana  retailers sold in Colorado in 2014 the  first year of legal weed sales in a  state that totals to almost 700 million  dollars worth of combined medical and  recreational pot sales and it's not just  people who like to light up dispensaries  sold 2.8 million dollars worth of  marijuana infused edible products which  include gummy bears tapenade and of  course the brownies for other states on  the fence of such a ruling last year  Colorado brought in 63 million dollars  in additional tax revenue from sales of  as much as well as 13 million dollars  from licenses and fees very lucrative